اطلعنا على قرار الرئيس
بالسماح بهذه الضربة الانتقامية،
ما الذي كان عليه وعلى الآخرين تقييمه؟ لقد أجرى
مناقشة مع
فريق الأمن القومي التابع له في الطريق إلى هنا إلى
أوتاوا في أعقاب غارة بطائرة بدون طيار
على قاعدتنا في سوريا وتلقى
توصيات  من
قادة وزارة الدفاع ومجتمع الاستخبارات
حول خيارات الرد التي
يمكن أن تبدو كما لو أنه اتخذ القرار أه
قريبًا جدًا في تلك المناقشة
أه للسماح بهذه الضربات ضد
هذه الأهداف المحددة، هل هناك
أي شيء يمكنك إخبارنا به عن
المقاول الأمريكي  قتل،
أخشى أنني لا أقصد أننا نحاول
منح العائلة بعض الوقت وفي
الفضاء هنا للحزن، لقد تلقوا للتو
أخبارًا مدمرة بالأمس، ونحن نعرف
أنه كان مواطنًا أمريكيًا
ومقاولًا يعمل لدينا في تلك
القاعدة تحديدًا  ولكن مرة أخرى، أعتقد أن بوبي
يمكنك أن تفهم أننا
سنمنحهم القليل من الخصوصية
الآن فقط لمتابعة سؤال بوبي
هناك، ما هي الأشياء التي
يمكن للولايات المتحدة أن تفعلها أي شيء للمساعدة في الحفاظ على
الموظفين و  المقاولون الأمريكيون آمنون هناك
جيدًا، الإجراءات التي اتخذناها بالأمس
هي جزء لا يتجزأ من هذا الجهد. لا
أقصد أننا سنعمل على حماية
موظفينا ومنشآتنا بأفضل ما نستطيع،
إنها بيئة خطيرة لقد قلتها
في الأعلى نحن.  إذا كانوا هناك لهزيمة داعش
لضمان الهزيمة الدائمة لداعش، فإنهم
ما زالوا يشكلون تهديدًا في سوريا، وما زالوا يشكلون
تهديدًا في العراق ليس قريبًا مما
كانوا عليه في عام 2014 بالطبع، لكنهم
ما زالوا هناك وما زالوا
يخططون  ما زالوا يخططون، وما زالوا يوفرون الموارد، وما
زالوا يتدربون، ومن
الواضح أنهم ما زالوا قادرين على
تنفيذ العمليات، ولدينا
مجموعات مسلحة مدعومة من
إيران هي التي تشن هذه
الهجمات ضد قواتنا
ومنشآتنا.  سنواصل أه
القيام بكل ما في وسعنا للدفاع عن
أنفسهم وإذا كان علينا الانتقام
كما فعلنا بالأمس فسنفعل ذلك